c'est c'est une pétille village
d'Astérix
des militants sont là en permanence jour
et nuit du haut de ses cabanes il
surveille l'évolution de la situation
le chantier est entouré par un grillage
et gardé par la police
une sirène donne le signal aux militant
c'est le top départ il est temps de
s'approcher du chantier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis une dizaine d'années un peu
partout en Europe les incidences
multiplient entre la police et de jeunes
anticapitalistes radicaux
cagoulé vêtu le noir il harcèle les
forces de l'ordre et s'en prennent au
symbole du capitalisme ou de l'État
[Musique]
leurs différences avec le reste de
l'extrême gauche
ils n'ont pas de chef pas d'organisation
structurée il ne se reconnaissent dans
aucun parti ou syndicat et surtout il
rejette la notion d'Etat perçu comme un
appareil répressif destiné à assurer la
domination du capitalisme
[Applaudissements]
il se réclame de l'anarchisme ou d'un
communisme anti-autoritaire ils veulent
une société sans État sans classe sans
domination sans autorité
les médias et le pouvoir les désignent
couramment sous le terme ultra gauche ou
d'un Arco autonome en France sous
Nicolas Sarkozy le gouvernement les a
souvent présentés comme un danger
ce sont des individus qui se
caractérisent par un rejet de toute
dialogue démocratique et par un discours
extrêmement violent je n'hésiterai pas à
appliquer la loi 1936 qui permet la
dissolution de certains groupes aux
bandes armées
qui se cache derrière ces capuches et
ses cagoules combien sont-ils jusqu'où
sont-ils prêts à aller dans la violence
sont-ils en mesure de déstabiliser les
pouvoirs en place
nous sommes allés en France en Italie et
en Grèce à la rencontre de ces nouveaux
révolutionnaires
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Paris automne 2011 c'est là que nous
rencontrons notre premier contact dans
le milieu anarcho autonome c'est un
militant parisien de longue date nous
l'appellerons Loïc il a 49 ans il
travaille dans l'édition emilite depuis
plus de 30 ans par le passé il a déjà
commis des violences lors de
manifestations alors il préférerait
rester anonyme il va nous expliquer à
quoi ressemblerait la société idéale des
anarchotonomes
l'essentiel c'est une société sans
classe sans état et sans argent qui se
débarrasse de l'exploitation et qui vit
de façon
autonome local c'est pas un peu utopique
quand même un peu à côté de la réalité
bah pour le moment bien sûr que si
évidemment mais devant la faillite
totale du capitalisme c'est dernière
décennies il va bien falloir commencer à
réfléchir à une autre façon d'organiser
la société
[Musique]
en France les zones Archos autonomes
regrouperaient selon la police environ
2000 personnes
la plupart en moins de 30 ans et sont le
plus souvent issus de classement yen
Loïc l'ancien nous met en garde ces
jeunes sont très hostiles aux médias et
ils ne nous sera pas facile de les
approcher
des médias et bon on peut on peut le
comprendre on peut comprendre les
raccourcis que font les médias donc
voilà les gens ne vont pas être
facilement abordables je pense
[Musique]
après des mois de prise de contact dans
le milieu anarcho autonome deux jeunes
militants parisiens acceptent de nous
parler Jeff et Fabrice on va et 24 ans
on va aller prendre un café à côté
eux aussi ont participé à des manies
violentes et préfèrent rester anonyme
l'un d'eux était à Strasbourg lors d'une
manifestation qui avait dégénéré en 2009
ce jour-là les anarchotonomes étaient
rassemblés contre la tenue d'un sommet
de l'OTAN 28 chefs d'États américains
européens célébraient le 60e
anniversaire de cette alliance militaire
né de la guerre froide l'Europe sera
désormais un pilier encore plus
important et plus fort de l'Alliance
[Musique]
le sommet donnera lieu à la plus
violente manifestation d'extrême gauche
que la France est connue ces dernières
années
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
présent à Strasbourg ne se sont jamais
exprimés dans les médias
[Applaudissements]
Jeff notre militant de 24 ans a
participé aux violences ce jour-là il
raconte
de protestation du pavés suite à quoi on
a eu des tiers de grenades suite à toi
une déco
de dégager parce que les musées
tellement
[Musique]
poussés
l'autorité avec des pavés contre un
arsenal quasiment militaire à base de
flashball de grenades etc et d'arriver à
passer pour moi c'est un sacré symbole
après cette première rencontre Jeff
accepte de nous présenter d'autres
militants rendez-vous et pris chez lui
quelque part dans Paris comme à chaque
fois qu'il se réunissent ces militants
se méfient de leur téléphone portable
s'il vous plaît
mes médecins peuvent être
une
avec Jeff il y a Fabrice et deux autres
militants de 21 ans Ronan et Chloé
ces jeunes n'ont rien de marginaux
ils ont tous un travail au fond des
études
ils sont issus de famille déjà politisés
à gauche par enseignants chercheurs
syndicalistes ils ont commencé par le
militantisme classique Chloé par exemple
a fait partie d'un syndicat étudiant
donc autant que je sois à l'électron
libre plutôt que d'être dans un dans un
groupe
[Musique]
soient pas pris en compte à partir de là
il nous reste plus qu'un choix c'est la
rébellion face face au pouvoir politique
qui sont dessus pour la démocratie c'est
top qui se gouvernent c'est pas le
peuple qui évite des gens gouverner
c'est hallucinant quand même et quand je
dis que je veux pas me dire mais tu es
un mauvais citoyen
je suis pas non au contraire enfin pour
moi c'est pas une bonne conscience que
j'achète le fait de voter ce n'est
qu'une qui est passive le fait de lutter
son étude qui est active pas de
participation aux institutions ni aux
élections mais un engagement politique
dans la rue dans les manifs au besoin on
usant d'une certaine violence
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le contexte de rêve la population s'est
rencontrées
oui dans ces cas-là je serai prêt moi à
titre personnel improvin arme et aller
me battre pour que ça change après
est-ce que j'ai envie là maintenant de
tuer des flics certainement pas
certainement pas moi je sors casser la
gueule ça va pas être là et pour
affronter la police lors des manifs ils
ont toute une panoplie
ça fait peur
ça fait pas chialer tu te sens beaucoup
moins voilà c'est c'est notre
lance-pierre c'est c'est pour les tirs
de longue portée en fait je pense que vu
les dégâts que j'ai fait parce que
pareil on n'est pas que des cailloux
dans c'est des roulements à billes des
fois qui font 3 cm de diamètre quand
vous envoyez ça à pleine force je peux
vous dire qu'à 100 m ça cognement
[Musique]
une semaine plus tard nous retrouvons
nos militants pour un entraînement un
peu particulier un entraînement au
combat de rue contre la police
lors d'une précédente manif ils ont
récupéré une grenade lacrymogène qui n'a
pas explosé ils vont s'en servir pour
leur exercice
[Musique]
objectif simuler une attaque contre les
CRS au milieu d'un nuage de lacrymogène
[Musique]
après les exercices de simulation les
travaux pratiques en ce jour de novembre
2011 Jeff et Fabrice nous ont donné
rendez-vous près de Valognes dans la
Manche ils doivent participer à une
manifestation contre le passage d'un
train de déchets nucléaire
demain comme à peu près une fois par an
un convoi radioactif doit partir de
l'usine de La Hague en direction de
l'Allemagne
alors que les organisations écologistes
traditionnelles comme Greenpeace ont
prévu de se retrouver devant la gare de
Valognes les anarchotonomes vont tenter
d'échapper à la surveillance de la
police
leur objectif
bloqué de force le convoi
derrière ce champ se cache un campement
qui accueille quelques 300 à 400
manifestants radicaux mais il nous est
interdit de le filmer à la nuit tombée
nous retrouvons Fabrice
oui on a l'impression qu'il y a vraiment
une grosse parano quand même dans le
temps par rapport aux médias on est on a
l'impression d'être un peu bah oui
effectivement
on est sur notre vie avec les décisions
comme un peu réfugiés on n'a pas
forcément envie qu'il a moins
d'information qui filtre après je sais
pas si on peut parler parano il y en a
forcément un petit peu on est toujours
sous tension et
oppresser donc
nous nous engageons à ne rien filmer sur
le camp en échange les militants nous
autorisent à passer la nuit avec eux et
à suivre toute l'action à leur côté
le lendemain à 6h du matin départ au
flambeau pour atteindre la voie ferrée
sans se faire repérer par la police il
passe par des chemins de campagne
mais un carrefour mauvaise rencontre
le jour se lève un hélicoptère des
forces de l'ordre surveille les
manifestants et lorsque les militants
s'approchent trop près de la voie ferrée
les forces de l'ordre attaque
[Musique]
il est 8h du matin le masque à gaz
devient indispensable
nous continuons à filmer Jeff et Fabrice
mais cela dérange certains militants
c'est
moi qui confiant
c'est bon par ici on avance on avance
Jeff veux en découdre mais un autre
militant n'est pas d'accord il craint
les représailles de la police
[Musique]
Jeff ne va pas résister en face de lui
un CRS
les premiers cailloux vols
on entend les voix des policiers
à la mi-journée la police tient toujours
les voix les manifestants sont à
quelques mètres seulement des rails les
forces de l'ordre vont menacer de
charger
[Musique]
par petit groupe les manifestants
harcèle la police
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la police finit par charger
les manifestants refus
[Musique]
dégâts collatéral un éleveur s'est fait
lui aussi allègrement gazé
c'est vous qui êtes dans la maison là où
il y a eu la bombe lacrymo
on s'excuse déjà
j'ai reçu beaucoup de gaz dans les yeux
apparemment
après 11h de manif les militants jettent
l'éponge qu'est-ce qu'il a dérisoire
baroud d'honneur il brûle des pneus sur
la route au JT régional de France 3 les
autorités qualifient les manifestants de
casseurs
ce que nous dit le procureur de la
République on l'écoute ce matin à
Cherbourg au micro de Rémi Mauger
le train réussira à partir mais avec
deux heures de retard
et cela suffit au bonheur de Jeff
[Musique]
sur les voies etc etc
la manifestation n'a fait que trois
blessés légers dont un policier ce
jour-là les militants n'avaient que des
cailloux à opposer à la police parfois
il n'hésite pas à recourir à des armes
plus sophistiquées
quelques semaines plus tard Jeff accepte
de nous montrer sa botte secrète
une petite bombe artisanale remplie de
clous qu'il jette sur les forces de
l'ordre lors de certaines manifestations
s'il est interpellé avec cet engin
explosif il risque en théorie 10 ans de
prison pour association de malfaiteurs
en vue d'une entreprise terroriste
[Musique]
et parfois vous les chargez plus ça peut
l'utiliser à combien de mètres
plus pour les jambes en fait
pour impressionner c'est pas quelque
chose qui fait vraiment pour vous
laisser c'est plus pour dégager
en l'air et dans l'oeil
vous êtes sûr vous prenez toutes les
précautions pour pas blesser gravement
quelqu'un
qui est blessé
toute manière a priori c'est pas les
manifestants donc c'est pas plus loin on
peut aussi le faire en le chargeant plus
en mettant des gros clous et là c'est un
truc qui veut faire des dégâts voir des
morts
qui pourraient tuer fanfic je pourrais
faire des grosses bandes qui pourraient
détruire des bâtiments avec des produits
qu'on peut trouver dans le commerce
c'est pas un souci seulement je les
ferai pas pourquoi parce que moi je
réponds à l'égalité je suis dans un
rapport d'égal égal dans les armes qui
sont envoyés par la police le jour ils
ont pris un rond des fusils et des
flingues ou tiroirs
ça peut être considéré par la justice
comme du terrorisme ça peut considéré
en même temps qu'est-ce qui n'est pas
considéré comme les terrorisme
aujourd'hui
Jeff n'est pas le seul à utiliser ce
genre de bombinette l'usage d'explosif
rester rare mais il s'est développé ces
dernières années chez les anarchos
autonomes et les autorités s'en inquiète
depuis l'arrivée à l'Elysée de Nicolas
Sarkozy en 2016 l'ultra gauche fait
figure d'épouvantail emblématique de
cette psychose du pouvoir l'affaire de
Tarnac en 2008
plus de 10 personnes ont été arrêtées à
Paris Rouen dans la Meuse et à Tarnac en
Corrèze au sein d'une communauté d'ultra
gauche
ultra gauche le terme fait peur
la veille 300 policiers gendarmes
cagoulés et armés jusqu'aux dents ont
investi le petit village corrézien de
Tarnac une centaine d'habitants à
l'année
ils arrêtent 9 militants suspectés
d'avoir bloqué une ligne TGV à l'aide de
crochet en fer posé sur les caténaires
[Musique]
même si la technique employée ne pouvait
pas faire de victimes les jeunes de
Tarnak sont accusés de terrorisme
l'un d'eux Julien Coupat fera 6 mois de
détention préventive
le lendemain de l'opération Michel
Alliot-Marie la ministre de l'Intérieur
de l'époque justifie les arrestations
par l'engagement politique des
interpellés ces individus se
caractérisent par le rejet de toute
expression démocratique et par l'appel à
des mouvements violents la démocratie ne
saurait tolérée une expression qui soit
radicale et qui soit violente nous la
tolérerons pas et tous les services de
police et de gendarmerie sont mobilisés
à cette fin
[Musique]
3 ans après les faits les jeunes de
Tarnac affirment qu'il n'y a aucune
preuve contre eux ils sont toujours dans
l'attente d'un procès pour Loïc militant
autonome depuis 30 ans c'est un fiasco
judiciaire qui illustre la volonté du
pouvoir sarkozyme d'étouffer toute
contestation
il y a une grande crainte de
contestation radicale de jonction entre
la colère
des ouvriers licenciés des banlieues de
la jeunesse et nous avons aujourd'hui au
pouvoir une droite extrême qui cherche à
criminaliser tout mouvement de
contestation c'est une façon de dire ne
vous révoltez pas faites attention ça va
mal aller si
si vous contestez de façon trop forte
l'ordre établi
et de fait depuis 2007 le pouvoir
demande au service de renseignement de
mettre le paquet sur les anarchos
autonomes c'est ce que va nous expliquer
ce policier récemment partir à la
retraite pendant plus de 20 ans il a
suivi les anarchos autonome c'est un des
meilleurs spécialistes de ce milieu
de place du système pour travailler sur
l'ultra gauche donc que ce soit la
sonorisation d'appartement le
renforcement des groupes de filatures
les écoutes téléphoniques pour
l'utilisation de d'appareil qui permet
de récupérer tous les numéros de
téléphone sur une manifestation donc on
fait des bases de données et si ensuite
on fait deux trois quatre humanistes et
que ce numéro revient systématiquement
sans seront considérés comme vous avez
des numéros de militants contestataires
[Musique]
manifestation
place est même un droit à
constitutionnel et en fait on fiche les
gens qui participent à des
manifestations
les anarchotonomes font peur au pouvoir
à tel point que le moindre petit acte de
délinquance dès qu'il implique un
anarchiste passe quasiment pour du
terrorisme
exemple avec un événement banal survenu
sur les Champs-Élysées le 10 mai 2016
quatre jours auparavant à peine élu
président Nicolas Sarkozy avait fêté sa
victoire avec des grands patrons du CAC
40 dans ce restaurant luxueux des
Champs-Élysées le désormais célèbre
Fouquet's 4 jours plus tard devant
l'établissement un incendie de voiture
comme il y en a 40000 en France chaque
année mais dans ce cas l'auteur a été
interpellé se dit anarchiste il
s'appelle Damien Signoret
vous reconnaissez sans droit je
reconnais je reconnais pas mal
d'ailleurs c'est quoi c'est le Fouquet
restaurant cité basse Mika c'est pas la
peine d'y aller ça sert à rien à
l'époque Damien a 20 ans il est ouvrier
au chômage et révolté par cet étalage de
luxe tapageur j'ai été cramé le
capot du nu qui est derrière en fait
c'est bien la maison du caviar juste en
face tranquille
Damien se fait arrêter immédiatement
après il restera de moins en prison mais
il ne regrette rien
vous baladez dans le quartier vous avez
un peu de trucs sur vous bon voilà vous
faites ce que vous avez à faire et puis
c'est tout quoi après j'ai assumé ce que
j'ai assumé mais voilà si c'était à
refaire concrètement je leur ferai
mais ce qui inquiète la police ce sont
les relations de Damien avec des
militants bien plus expérimentés
notamment avec cet homme Pascot 56 ans à
l'époque militant anarchiste depuis
l'âge de 14 ans présent dans toutes les
manifs les plus chaudes et fichiers
depuis des années il n'était pas sur les
lieux de l'incendie mais il hébergé
d'amis à un moment des faits deux jours
plus tard la police l'interpelle à son
domicile
alors ils sont rentrés dans la maison
ils ont commencé à
fouiller partout et puis à défoncer tout
dans la baraque
ils ont trouvé quelque chose de
particulier qui les intéressait ils ont
saisi des choses ils ont amené un
puisqu'il trouvait rien bon ils ont
saisi bon des documents pas mal de
documents de documents anarchistes des
bouquins des livres
Paco sera entendu par des policiers
antiterroristes les forces de l'ordre ne
trouvent rien de compromettant à son
domicile et pourtant elle le considère
comme le cerveau de cette opération mais
pas coup affirme n'avoir rien su de ce
que faisait son invité Damien Signoret
d'accord donc il part et imagine ce
n'est pas où est là non plus et puis
j'ai pas le savoir non plus quoi c'était
ça c'est c'est à qui qu'on n'a pas se
donner des données trop d'informations
d'accord c'est à dire que les gens quand
ils viennent chez moi ils sont libres
ils font ce qu'ils veulent ils sont
responsables et libres vous les fouillez
pas vous les flics
paco est condamné à quatre mois de
prison pour complicité de dégradations
par incendie sans preuve incontestable
de son implication dans cette affaire
surveillance policiera cru
interpellation de militants justice très
sévère les anarchotonomes sont dans le
collimateur
pourtant pour François l'ancien policier
spécialiste de ce milieu la mouvance ne
représente pas pour l'instant une réelle
menace
il n'y a pas de d'organisation du carnet
plus la particularité c'est que c'est
des attaques contre les biens on a
rarement des attaques contre les
personnes les seules attaques contre les
personnes se sont les forces de l'ordre
en termes de en terme de manifs on n'a
pas des attaques contre
la responsables responsable politique
responsable du gouvernemental mais ce
qui fait peur au pouvoir c'est quand
certaines occasions les anarchos
autonomes de toute l'Europe sont
capables de se rassembler et de faire
des dégâts par exemple lors des grands
sommets internationaux
gènes 2001 c'est un peu là que tout a
commencé
[Musique]
le 20 juillet le port italien est en
état de siège
ce jour-là il accueille un sommet du G8
les 8 pays les plus riches du monde
le symbole de l'arrogance des puissants
vis-à-vis des peuples pour l'extrême
gauche
300 000 manifestants affluent de toute
l'Europe
Pacifique pour la plupart mais les
esprits s'échauffent rapidement
les affrontements commencent
des militants films
[Musique]
en quelques heures la police perd le
contrôle de la situation
et se met à taper sur tout ce qui bouge
OK
[Musique]
cet après-midi là alors que des
manifestants en cercle un véhicule des
forces de l'ordre la situation va
basculer pris de panique un carabinetti
[Musique]
se manifestant allongé au sol vient de
recevoir une balle dans la tête il meurt
sur le coup
il avait 23 ans il s'appelait Carlo
Giuliani
le lendemain 21 juillet une grande
manifestation a lieu en la mémoire de
Carlo Giuliani
dans toutes les rues de la ville la
colère monte contre la police accusé
d'avoir tiré délibérément
[Musique]
en deux jours des meute 600 manifestants
étaient blessés
une répression qui a marqué toute une
génération d'italien
Turin la grande ville industrielle dans
le nord-ouest du pays
c'est là que nous avons retrouvé un
ancien participant aux manifestations de
Gênes
Diane Luca pitavino a 35 ans pour gagner
sa vie les concepteurs de sites internet
mais sa principale activité c'est la
politique problème c'est un des
militants les plus en vus de Turin il
nous emmène dans un des fiefs d'extrême
gauche de la ville la faculté de l'être
donc là c'est la salle du collectif qui
on fait des réunions on prépare les
initiatives
la répression de gènes c'est l'événement
fondateur de son engagement politique 11
ans après il est encore marqué
ils ont battu beaucoup de gens il y a
même eu quelque chose comme la torture
plus ou moins dans le dans les prisons
de ceux qui venaient arrêter en disant
ça m'a bouleversé sa ministre ça m'a
initié à la politique depuis Diane Lucas
se passionne pour l'histoire de
l'extrême gauche italienne une longue
histoire
il nous emmène dans une librairie
politique tenue par des militants
d'extrême gauche les autonomes comme on
les appelle en Italie il serait à peu
près 10000 aujourd'hui ici on vend des
livres politiques notamment sur l'âge
d'or des années 70
souvenir nostalgie d'une révolution
perdue
ah ça c'est bien
l'année 76 et 117 à Milan tous les
sangliers il y avait des protèges comme
ça
[Musique]
l'Italie des années 70 c'est un mythe
dans toute l'extrême gauche européenne
de la violence politique de ces
années-là le monde a surtout retenu les
terroristes des Brigades rouges et
l'assassinat en 1978 daldo Moreau ancien
Premier ministre mais le mouvement
italien était bien plus large les
autonomes étaient à peu près 100 000 des
ouvriers des étudiants des intellectuels
se mobilisent pour renverser le pouvoir
ils
occupent des usines des quartiers
entiers le pays est au bord de
l'insurrection les autonomies italien
font trembler l'état certains militants
étaient même armés
Diane Lucas semble presque vivre dans le
fantasme de ces années-là est-il pour
autant partisan de la lutte armée il
nous emmène au centre social à cathauna
un espace occupé illégalement depuis 15
ans et autogéré par les autonomes
c'est là qu'il habite et qu'il a accepté
de répondre à nos questions pour lui
dans les années à venir la violence
politique sera inévitable
c'est sûr qu'il y aura des semaines mais
ces statistiques si on va voir
c'est nécessaire parce que le pouvoir
constitué
il obéissent un seul loi et c'est ce de
rapport de force
de la solution d'un certain conditions
[Musique]
palestiniennes il y a des loutarmé
je suis sûr que ça marche pas ce
moment-là un niveau conscient en Italie
c'est un niveau suicidaire et qui
n'arrivait rien politiquement pour moi
pour les autonomies italien le combat du
moment est purement local
ce soir réunion exceptionnelle de
militants pour préparer une
manifestation contre un projet de TGV
Lyon-Turin leve en Italie pour ces
opposants c'est un projet inutile et
désastreux pour l'environnement
et de fait le projet pharaonique les
travaux doivent durer 20 ans la ligne
Lyon-Turin devrait coûter plus de 8
milliards d'euros elle nécessiterait le
percement d'un tunnel de 53 km sous les
Alpes plus long que le tunnel sous la
Manche mais surtout la ligne doit
traverser une petite vallée italienne
préservée le Val De Sousa à 50 km de
Turin
dans la région la population se mobilise
depuis 20 ans contre le taf de tous âges
de tout milieux sociaux il manifeste
régulièrement une lutte qui fait la une
des journaux italiens et qui divise le
pays en 2005 les autonomes ont rejoint
le mouvement ce qui les attire dans
cette lutte populaire c'est son
potentiel révolutionnaire ce qui est
intéressant c'est même plus le côté
écologique ce n'est même plus les
projets en tant que ça mais c'est
la force le disant les relations
humaines les rapports sociales qu'il a
été capable d'instituer et cette
richesse sociale et des relations qui se
construit là-bas qu'il a vraiment de
vieux retraités de
travailleurs du type des enseignants des
étudiants avec une ou des sciences
sociales de la ville et c'est un mélange
très très intéressant et très très fort
politiquement et qui fait beaucoup plus
beaucoup peur d'ailleurs
le lendemain rendez-vous dans le Val de
Suza pour tenter d'occuper le chantier
au milieu de ces petits villages alpins
2000 personnes manifestent contre le taf
le TGV Lyon-Turin et puis la foule
emprunte un petit sentier de montagne
qu'est-ce qui se passe
là la voix c'était bloquée juste
derrière la police par la police et donc
comme on veut essayer d'arriver près des
chantiers
qui passe par Léo un parti qui passe par
en bas
la manifestation se transforme en
véritable randonnée sportive des
hélicoptères de police survolent la zone
il nous faudra plus d'une heure pour
arriver au lieu du rassemblement tout
près du chantier
sorti de nulle part un campement de
fortune les habitants de la vallée
l'appellent le président la forteresse
en français
c'est une PTV
des militants sont là en permanence jour
et nuit du haut de ses cabanes il
surveille l'évolution de la situation
le chantier est entouré par un grillage
et gardé par la police
une sirène donne le signal au militants
c'est le top départ il est temps de
s'approcher du chantier les forces de
l'ordre sont nombreuses plusieurs
centaines de policiers ont été mobilisés
[Musique]
la police commence à tirer des gaz
lacrymogènes pour empêcher les
manifestants de s'approcher du chantier
mais ceci se dirige vers les policiers
on nous demande d'arrêter de filmer
[Musique]
nous continuons néanmoins tourner
discrètement
une véritable bataille rangée s'engage
au gaz lacrymo de la police les
manifestants répliquent à coups de
cailloux et de fumigènes
les militants lancent tout ce qu'ils ont
sous la main
même des troncs d'arbres
les hélicoptères de la police arrosent
les manifestants de bombe lacrymogène
on y voit plus rien
l'atmosphère est irrespirable
même avec un masque à gaz
[Musique]
c'est la débandade les manifestants
abandonnent leur campement de fortune
la police occupe les lieux
la bataille est terminée les opposants
au TGV rentrent chez eux
le soir même l'événement est à la une de
tous les JTS qui insiste sur la violence
de la manifestation encore et toujours
des incidents encore des affrontements
encore des tensions sur la question du
TGV dans le Val De Sousa
le lendemain nous nous rendons dans un
des fiefs des opposants au train
boussole et nos un bourg de 5000
habitants dans le Val De Sousa une terre
rouge très marquée à gauche et au lieu
de la résistance antifasciste pendant la
Seconde Guerre mondiale
ici la stratégie des Autonomes semble
payante ils ont le soutien de la
population locale
là c'est le café librairie Le QG des
opposants outave les consommateurs ne
parlent que de la manif d'hier et de ce
qu'il considère comme une désinformation
des médias
c'est comme ça tu ouvres le journal il
n'y a que de la violence
tu ouvres le site de La Stampa de Turin
d'hier mais la Stan pas c'est un grand
quotidien quand même
et là il dit un arsenal a été trouvé au
QG des opposants au TGV il y avait des
outils un marteau une pince il y avait
une hache aussi mais c'était pour couper
du bois
la violence de l'État italien personne
n'en parle et pourtant ici l'État est
violent répressif on a l'impression
d'être de retour dans les années 20 avec
l'autre chose la Mussolini
mais ça ne vous gêne pas d'être soutenu
par les autonomes vous n'avez pas
l'impression d'être manipulé
ils nous ont toujours aidés ils nous ont
toujours aidés
ce sont eux qui ont fait plein de
manifestations de soutien ce sont eux
qui souvent calme les vieux de la vallée
tu vois tu as le vieux avec une pierre
dans la main et le jeune militant
autonome qui arrive et le calme et lui
dit de rester tranquille tu vois
[Musique]
dans le Val De Souza la population a
trouvé avec les autonomes des alliés
mais dans le reste de l'Italie l'extrême
gauche est loin d'avoir un tel soutien
il y a un seul pays en Europe où les
contestataires radicaux ont une
véritable assise populaire
c'est la Grèce
un pays au bord de la faillite
[Musique]
depuis 2009 les plans d'austérité s'y
succèdent avec des conséquences lourdes
sur la population un jeune surdeux est
au chômage le salaire minimum a été
diminué de 22% cette année il est
aujourd'hui à 580 euros du coup depuis
trois ans le pays vit au rythme de
manifestation de plus en plus violente
en première ligne on trouve souvent les
anarchistes
les anarchistes la Grèce c'est un peu
leur paradis
la première chose qui frappe en arrivant
à Athènes c'est qu'ils sont partout à
tous les coins de rue le célèbre a
entouré le symbole de l'anarchisme sur
des graffitis des affiches et même des
journaux et avec la crise la révolte des
annares contre le pouvoir et de plus en
plus populaire
ce que veulent les anarchistes
j'aimerais bien qu'on l'est ici une
société sans pouvoir et solidaire
vu la nécessité de faire tomber ce
gouvernement et cette politique je
comprends la réaction elle est légitime
je suis plutôt d'accord avec eux mais
quand il détruit tout c'est dommage non
les familles n'ont plus de quoi se
nourrir dont elles ont du mal à
satisfaire les besoins les plus
élémentaires évidemment que la violence
est justifiée
[Musique]
le centre de la contestation c'est
l'école polytechnique la plus grande
faculté de sciences du pays un véritable
sanctuaire pour l'extrême gauche la
police ni pénètre jamais
[Musique]
et les journalistes très rarement les
caméras ils sont en principe interdites
pour pouvoir rentrer nous nous sommes
rapprochés d'un groupe de militants de
la mouvance anarchiste
vague Élise à 32 ans il est chômeur et
se définit comme anti autoritaire c'est
lui qui nous fait entrer dans les lieux
salut ça va
à l'intérieur c'est l'effervescence
partout des stands et des slogans
révolutionnaires c'est un jour
inhabituel
les organisations d'extrême gauche
commémorent le 17 novembre 1973 une date
mythique pour la démocratie grecque les
étudiants de l'École polytechnique
s'étaient alors soulevé contre la
dictature d'extrême droite dite des
colonels qui tombera finalement six mois
plus tard
dans la faculté tout le monde se prépare
à la manifestation du lendemain
pour vagalyser ses camarades c'est un
rendez-vous incontournable
à votre depuis tous les ans on fête la
révolte de Polytechnique
pendant trois jours il y a des
événements et toute la jeunesse vient
des étudiants toutes les organisations
politiques d'extrême gauche
c'est pour ça qu'il y a ces tables où il
distribue leur tract leur journaux
jusqu'au jour du 17 novembre où ça se
termine par une manifestation
vague Élise nous emmène à son QG sur
lequel flotte le drapeau rouge et noir
des anarchistes
nous sommes dans le quartier d'exartia à
deux pas de l'École polytechnique
tout le monde ici l'appelle le quartier
des anarchistes
le lieu de réunion de vagelli c'est de
ses camarades s'appellent un endroit
autogéré par des militants anarchistes
on y édite un journal contestataire on y
donne des cours d'alphabétisation et on
s'y rencontre autour du bar on y fait
des conférences des débats des concerts
et surtout on y parle politique et
révolution toute la journée ici chacun a
ses raisons d'être révoltées au
lieu comme un anarchiste
pas exactement pas encore en tout cas
j'ai découvert le mouvement
révolutionnaire à la quarantaine
[Musique]
et quel âge avez-vous 41 ans
avant je croyais encore que le système
politique pouvait nous apporter une
solution maintenant j'ai bien vu qu'il
en était incapable
avant je gagnais 1000 euros par mois
et aujourd'hui avec cette crise
économique le plan d'austérité qu'on
nous a imposé
je ne gagne plus que 350 euros
nous-mêmes c'est quoi la solution pas de
système politique
du tout exactement ça va pas être
évident vu la période que l'on vit
tout le monde aujourd'hui se révolte
c'est vraiment le moment pour faire la
révolution
en tout cas c'est ce que je crois
et vous vous êtes pour une révolution
maintenant en Grèce
oui bien sûr personnellement j'ai
toujours été pour la révolution mais
aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression que c'est
tout le peuple qui veut ça
et vous êtes prête à vous battre contre
la police
[Musique]
évidemment
frapper
vous voulez que je fasse je vais leur
dire ok ok venez je suis pas Jésus non
la Révolution et la non-violence ça va
pas ensemble
la révolution sans combat c'est pas une
révolution elle est prête pour le combat
on est tous prêts au combat
mais la violence dépasse parfois le
simple combat de rue
depuis trois ans des policiers des juges
et un journaliste ont été assassinés et
les attentats à l'explosif se
multiplient des actions commises par
deux groupes muscules au nom étranges la
conspiration des cellules de feu et la
secte des révolutionnaires des groupes
se réclamant de l'anarchisme mais qui ne
sont pas reconnus comme tels par le
reste du mouvement
nous demandons à vagelli ce qu'il pense
du terrorisme
je ne suis pas forcément contre la lutte
armée bon la secte des révolutionnaires
ils ont fait des actions où je suis
vraiment contre parce qu'ils ont tué des
gens pour les cellules de feu c'est
différent je trouve qu'ils ont choisi
des cibles symboliques sans vouloir tuer
quelqu'un il voulait juste montrer leur
présence et faire comprendre que eux
aussi peuvent utiliser la violence donc
je les regarde un peu plus positivement
le lendemain c'est la date anniversaire
de la révolte des étudiants qui a
entraîné la chute du régime des colonels
on se prépare pour la manif certaines se
pomponnent aux couleurs de l'anarchie
bien sûr
[Musique]
d'une française c'est comme ça qu'il
mette leur foulards les Français non
préparation de banderoles de drapeaux le
tout dans une ambiance très festive
[Musique]
et il faut aussi l'équipement de base
lunettes de plongée et masque pour se
protéger des gaz lacrymogènes ou
chimiques nous ne sommes pas bien
équipés les militants nous conseillent
d'acheter des masques à gaz ce n'est pas
bien difficile à trouver dans une grande
avenue d'Athènes un magasin de vêtements
expose en devanture le kit du parfait
manifestant
13 heures c'est l'heure de la manif les
militants de nos sauterons se retrouvent
d'autres militants anarchistes et
d'extrême gauche
distribution de masques à gaz même pour
les plus âgés
malgré le masque à gaz il nous manque un
ingrédient essentiel dans la panoplie du
parfait manifestant grec
photinie insiste pour nous appliquer
cette pommade qui empêche les gaz de
pénétrer dans la peau
autour des militants de nos sauterros et
de leur drapeau un curieux manège
à chaque manif on achète des bâtons pour
les drapeaux les gens ils prennent les
bateaux ils ne les ramène jamais et
aujourd'hui on a décidé que les gens
nous payent pour qu'on puisse au moins
racheter des bâtons mais qu'est-ce
qu'ils font avec ces bâtons
rien c'est de l'autodéfense vraiment
juste de l'autodéfense oui oui
l'autodéfense
16h30 la manif démarre enfin
nous sommes au milieu du cortège
anarchiste certains manifestants
cagoulés sont très jeunes
les forces de police sont très
nombreuses les manifestants s'approchent
du Parlement
il y a environ 8000 manifestants
anarchistes à leur passage les badauds
applaudissent
la manifestation passe tout près du
Parlement bien gardé par la police
anti-émeute
vagelys et quelques dizaines de
militants ce poste juste au pied de
l'Assemblée nationale
comme un défi il déploie une banderole
anarchiste face au symbole de la
démocratie grecque
les passants continuent d'aller venir
comme si de rien n'était la routine en
Grèce
les militants de nos sauterros sont bien
seuls les autres anarchistes qui
devaient les rejoindre on choisit un
autre parcours en leur a donné des
bâtons mais ils ne sont pas venus
ils ne sont pas du tout préparés
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire de plus mais
peut-être que plus tard en rentrant on
va s'amuser
mais il n'y aura pas d'amusement avec la
police pour les militants de nos
sauteros les forces de l'ordre sont trop
nombreuses
c'est dans une rue adjacente au
Parlement qui éclateront des
affrontements à coups de cocktail
Molotov
la Grèce est au bord de l'insurrection
et vit au rythme de manifestation de
plus en plus violente
le 12 février 2012 lors de l'adoption
par le Parlement d'un énième plan
d'austérité les anarchistes Grecs suivis
par une large partie de la population ce
sont très violemment affrontés avec les
forces de l'ordre
les plus déterminés ont tenté
d'incendier des bâtiments il y a eu 45
départs de feu à Athènes
[Musique]
ailleurs en Europe on est loin de cette
situation quasi insurrectionnelle pour
l'instant mais les pouvoirs politiques
notamment en France ont peur de la
contagion si la crise s'aggravait les
anarchotonomes pourraient entraîner avec
eux une partie de la population dans une
contestation beaucoup plus radicale